des visages inquiet un avenir incertain
et un sentiment d'insécurité permanent
voilà à quoi ressemble le quotidien des
habitants de diffa cette ville du sud
est du niger à la frontière avec le
nigeria vit en état de siège
un responsable boko haram et ces
dissidences conséquence la population et
à pleurer est prise à la gorge
économiquement non la vie ici à des
femmes s'étant facile envie d'aller si
vite et on n'a pas d'emploi
la dégradation du climat l'élevage
l'agriculture le commerce
tout ça ça ne va pas le travail on n'a
pas tout ça c'est à cause de
l'insécurité vraiment surtout surtout du
de la mauvaise gouvernance de nos paies
de ne pas la personne n'ose prononcer le
nom du groupe islamiste nigérian par
peur de représailles
boko haram a des oreilles partout un
rêve pour ces nigériens retrouver leur
domicile
en effet la région de diffa accueille
trois cent mille réfugiés et déplacés du
niger et du nigeria selon les chiffres
de l'onu
une situation insoutenable et un enjeu
considérable pour cette offre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mohamed bazoum incarne un mince espoir
pour une gouvernance différentes favori
de cette élection présidentielle le
successeur annoncé de mahamadou issoufou
fait un pari osé ramener dans leurs
villages d'origine d'ici fin 2021
les centaines de milliers de déplacés et
réfugiés fuyant les violences de boko
haram dans le sud est du pays
issu d'une ethnie minoritaire ce
travailleur acharné aura s'il est élu un
défi colossal rétablir l'ordre et la
sécurité dans son pays
nos forces de sécurité intérieure
nous avons un programme de recrutement
nous avons misé de votre problème de
recrutement de jeunes gens de la région
du lac tchad de la région du divin du
moins les ont été formés pensons que
avec des personnes qui seront vraiment
opérationnels les tentateurs points nous
aurons de voir résultats et nous
réduisons la sécurité le dossier
sécuritaire avec les quatre autres pays
du g5 sel est la priorité du futur
gouvernement
l'éducation sera le fer de lance de ce
projet ambitieux pour éviter que les
camps de réfugiés deviennent des repères
jihadistes
les quelques 7,4 millions de nigériens
appelés aux urnes ce dimanche veulent du
concret pour pouvoir espérer retrouver
une vidange